ich freue mich sehr darauf sie mitnehmen
zu dürfen in dem digitalen raum im
hinblick darauf wie man eine lehre und
lernen geben gestalten kann mit
hafencity ich unterhalte mich mit meinen
studenten ab und an mal über so digitale
leer und lernumgebungen im bereich der
lmu spricht man natürlich immer über
moodle weil das natürlich das
favorisierte system da in den usa ich
erhalte eigentlich immer so zwei
rückmeldungen also die erste rückmeldung
das ganze positiv sie stemmten finden es
gut dass wir es zu ziehen immer häufiger
verwenden dass sie dort an ihre kurse
finden das sozusagen ein lern und
leerraum gibt wo alles und vorhandene
ist nach so ein bisschen zögern kommen
dann aber auch das wird der einwand ja
aber optisch wäre es halt manchmal nicht
ganz so ansprechen und manchmal würde es
auch er seine dateien depot gleichen
ganz verhallt wenig interaktiv er so ein
bisschen statisch und also ich
persönlich glaube dass es ganz viele
gründe dafür gibt warum das so ist und
ich glaube dass diese gründe zum teil
auch sehr gute gründe sind das hat
natürlich auch immer etwas mit der zeit
zu tun die man als dozierende hat oder
aufwenden kann um sein rudel raum etwas
schöner zu machen aber es gibt natürlich
auch ganz viele möglichkeiten um mehr
aus moodle rauszuholen und eine
möglichkeit die ich für mich entdeckt
hat und die mich auch sehr begeistert
ist hans p und 13
hauptpunkte die ich daran sehr gut finde
also zum einen digital und interaktiv
das ist einfach zu gestalten das was
rauskommt ist schön und kann auch sehr
farbenfroh sein und der dritte punkt ist
dass alles was man erstellt überhaupt
wie man sehr leicht teilen kann ich
finde diesen aspekt des teilens sehr
schön und auch vielleicht meine
persönliche hoffnung für die zukunft der
lehre dass wir einfach alle mehr
miteinander kooperieren und ideen und
inhalte aufteilen können und hafen macht
es uns eben sehr einfach
die nächsten 20 minuten gebe ich mir
ganz ganz kurze einführungen was hans de
ist damit möchte ich mich gar nicht so
lange aufhalten sondern wir schauen uns
dann er so fest unmögliches perfektes
beispiel an
ich habe im rahmen eines multiplikatoren
projekts im arabisch 20 digitale tests
auf moodle erstellt eben unter der
verwendung von hafens und der ausblick
wäre es von mir vielleicht also entweder
sie haben ganz viele fragen da freue ich
mich auch drauf oder wir könnten ein
bisschen darüber sprechen wie man
vielleicht diese best practice die gehen
auch miteinander teilen kann und mehr
ins gespräch kommen kann über der
erstellung von hafencity man muss
vielleicht noch so als kleine zusatz
dazu sagen also gleicher unterrichte
unterrichten beschäftige ich natürlich
vor allem mit lehrmaterial auf arabisch
das ist so eine besonderheit des
arabischen dass wir ich muss sehr wenig
lehrmaterial haben und für den
universitären unterricht umfasst gar
keins deswegen ist es aufgabe aller
lehrkräfte in deutschland bald auch sehr
viel lehrmaterial einfach selber zu
erstellen ich glaube das ist was was man
in anderen sprachen wie englisch
französisch eher weniger hart als da
einfach viel gibt worauf man
zurückgreifen kann also alles was zeige
ist soetwas bayerisch angehauchte
aber da müssen sie jetzt darüber
hinwegsehen und ich glaube dass der
transfer auch ihre eigenen lehrinhalte
eigentlich sehr gut und sehr leicht
gelingen kann
was haben man halte ich mich nicht so
lange auf so ein paar basisinformationen
aber ist eine software zum erstellen von
digitalen lerninhalten diese software
ist so frei und quelloffen und was uns
natürlich sehr entgegen kommen wir
können das alles im rudel erstellen und
auch dann direkt moodle einbetten also
man muss sich nicht auf einer externen
website anmelden oder erst irgendwo ein
konto eröffnen sondern wir machen das
direkt google und es steht wirklich sehr
viele interaktive inhalte zur verfügung
ich habe ihnen zwei screenshots
mitgebracht von der hafenseite selber
damit sie so einen ersten einblick
bekommen was gibt es da alles bekommt
enteilt und ich finde da ist für jeden
fach und lehrbereich ist dabei das ist
nur eine auswahl von insgesamt starb im
moment ins 50 und da ist eigentlich nur
die fantasie des lehrenden oder die
lehrpersonen gesagt um aus diesen
content teils was passendes zu machen
für die eigenen lehrer
mir ist nicht so ganz klar ob sie alle
schon
super im bescheid wissen über
harfenspiel oder ob sie alle gut wissen
wie man das jetzt auch in module
verwenden kann ich habe gemerkt es würde
den rahmen des vortrags etwas sprengen
wenn ich das noch technisch zeige
deswegen habe ich eine kleine anleitung
geschrieben und ich versuche mal ganz
kurz die in den chat man rein zu ziehen
und es geht
klinsmann kann kein dokument teilen aber
während interesse hat könnte sich
einfach in aachen dann noch mal bei mir
melden also ich hab einfach die
kurzzusammenfassung beschrieben was
machen sie da was sind die schritte um
einen hd modul in google zu kreieren ich
kann es einfach jetzt im rahmen nicht
mal
ich selber bin zuerst mal 2009/10
bewarfen die in berührung gekommen wir
haben im rahmen eines multiplikatoren
projekt zum letzten jahrgang der noch
finanziert wurde eine lernplattform
entwerfen können auch nudeln und wir
haben eigentlich versucht im rahmen
dieses projekt ein bedürfnis der stirn
nachzukommen denn die studierenden bei
uns haben auch den wunsch den eigenen
leistungsstand regelmäßig testen zu
können überprüfen zu können sind sich
immer unsicher ob sie die kann man jetzt
wirklich verstanden haben ob ihr vokabel
wissen ausreicht ob sie jetzt
weitermachen können mit dem kurs oder
nicht ursprünglich haben wir die ganz
pragmatische lösung gehabt dass wir halt
einfach nach ihrer lektionen zu einem
kleinen schriftlichen test geschrieben
haben da hat sich herausgestellt dass es
sehr zeitaufwendig denn obwohl unser
fachbereich sehr klein ist da habe ich
wird auch ganz viel über das nebenfach
gelegt und wir haben im wintersemester
immer so ein schnitt 130 anmeldungen und
wenn man natürlich auch nur die hälfte
anwesend ist in diesem test nicht
schreibt man hat sehr viel zu tun und
das merkt man dann eigentlich schon ganz
stark zum anderen hat es dann raus
gestellt in dem moment wo wir einen
schriftlichen test aus teilen wollen die
studierenden gar nicht mehr so genau
wissen was ihr eigene leistungsstand ist
und sind dann da auch eher zurückhaltend
weil es natürlich auch nicht unbedingt
wollen dass dann jemand anderer darauf
schaut dass eine korrektur erfolgt das
war eher so ein bisschen unbeliebt daher
haben wir eigentlich folgendes
eingestellt also wie kann man den
einzelnen übungen strukturiert so im
digitalen raum verankern dass eine
lernumgebung entsteht innerhalb derer
die stirn selbständige ihren eigenen
wissensstand über
also wir wollten eigentlich drei sachen
wir wollten digitale tests haben mit
einer festen struktur ermöglicht für
jedes kapitel im buch sprich haben
natürlich erste buch 12 ist test
gebraucht wir wollten zweitens dass
diese tests dem interaktiv sind also
dass studenten auch etwas machen müssen
wenn sie schon im digitalen raum
unterwegs sind und sie sollten auch
ansprechend sein das ganze sollte
optisch irgendwie schön ausschauen
drittens wir wollten dass eine
selbständige bearbeitung möglich ist
nach eigenem zeit befinden und dass die
studenten auch sofort eine rückmeldung
erhalten also dass keine korrektur mehr
durch uns sozusagen notwendig wir sind
dann darauf gekommen als lösung das buch
zu verwenden in nudel ich glaub im ein
oder anderen ist das buch schon bekannt
was es zu finden unter den
arbeitsmaterialien und es ist eigentlich
ein ganz klassisches buch würde denn so
aussehen sie haben rechts und
inhaltsverzeichnis du klingst haben sie
ganz klassischer weise text also in
kapiteln unterkapitel und fügen halt
text ein bilder und grafiken was auch
immer sie wollen oder eben hafen übungen
das ist möglich hafens die übungen in
dieses buch zu integrieren und damit
entsteht eigentlich so einen lernraum im
kleinen das buch ist in so einem
komplett abgeschlossene einheit mit den
inhalten da drin und dadurch hat es halt
eine sehr schöne struktur ist es für die
studenten sehr klar wie sie vorgehen
müssen um so einen rückblick für eine
lektion zu machen und man hat halt links
sozusagen diesen platz diese hafen
übungen einzubetten ich werde ihnen
jetzt im weiteren verlauf einfach mal
einzelne hafen vier übungen zeigen damit
sie auch ein bett ein gefühl dafür
bekommen was also möglich ist ich habe
mir gedacht das ist vielleicht ein
bisschen langweilig das jetzt so in 2d
sich anschauen zu müssen deswegen habe
ich diese
übungen auch mal auf eine externe
webseite noch geladen ich hoffe dass das
klappt dass ich ihnen
den link an einen chat schicken kann und
dann könnten sie einfach nebenbei ein
bisschen mit klicken wenn sie wollen
also dass buch und sagen als rahmen
fehlt hier ist natürlich leider weil das
kann ich das nicht anzeigen aber die
einzelnen übungen sind dort zu finden
und wenn sie wollen und dann im zweiten
screen haben können sie das einfach
aufrufen und sozusagen nebenbei ein
bisschen mitmachen so wie sieht es jetzt
aus wenn man diese hfg übungen in das
buch integriert zum beispiel so das wäre
jetzt die erste aufgabe wir sind jetzt
schon ein bisschen gesprungen eine
kollektion im rückblick und zwar zur
punktierung also obwohl sie vielleicht
es keine experten des arabischen sind
das recht bewusst ist gibt 1 punkt und
die gesetzt werden müssten auf die
verschiedenen buchstaben und das kann
durchaus den sinn des satzes ganz schön
verändern wenn die punkte falsch gesetzt
werden hier werde also die aufgabe die
studenten müssen die sätze abschreiben
müssen punkt setzen und können sich
danach aber selber überprüfen indem sie
diesen roten balken und sagen von rechts
nach links ziehen dann würde der ganzen
satz in punktierte form auftauchen das
ist ein beispiel aus dem bereich immer
die position dass gleich zwei bilder
sozusagen die übereinander liegen und
durch das ziehen des reglers kommt eben
das andere bildern zum vorschein
ein weiteres beispiel aus dem
unendlichen korpus von hp wäre das
beispiel die taschen wir haben fünf
studenten von uns ihre natürlich
fiktiven telefonnummern eingesprochen
die aufgabe der studenten ist es hier im
hörverständnis die nummern rauszuhören
dann mit arabischen ziffern einzutippen
und danach als selber zu überprüfen ob
sie die ziffern und ob sie die
telefonnummern richtig aus gehört haben
zahlen ich weiß nicht ich habe nicht so
erfahrungen mit anderen sprachen
unterrichten dynamischen sind die sehr
komplex und das bei studenten
tendenziell schwer das ist halt schön
für die studierenden weil sie sich hier
so viel zeit nehmen
wie sie halt wollen und sie können sich
das hat auch fünf mal anhören wird sehen
mal wenn ich zeit auch im unterricht
würde ich immer noch dreimal sagen okay
jetzt machen wir mal weiter aber damit
verliere ich natürlich ganz viele die
halt vielleicht noch nicht so schnell
jetzt nicht dabei waren
ein weiteres beispiel aus
die hotspots würde so eine aufgabe sein
hier müssen die studenten stellen
markieren alle wörter die in irgendeiner
form personen bezeichnet denn bereits
markiert ist stabil ist dann erst ihren
der mitte hat schon einen grünen haken
bekommen wurde schon das richtig
markiert und der student erhält dann
gleich unten drunter auch noch mal ein
hinweis für das heißt ausländer und man
kann noch eine weitere frage nachgeben
und diesem fall wäre zum beispiel wissen
sie noch wie man die änderung des box
nennt das möchte ich ihnen jetzt nicht
vorenthalten ist ein ist so heißt wenn
man jetzt auf ein anderes wort klicken
würde wie zum beispiel rechts oben hier
ach was sind die nachrichten dann würde
sofort ein rotes xr scheinen das student
wirst du sofort ob er hat nicht richtig
geklickt dann müsste weiter suchen und
unten drunter wird angezeigt ob die
einst von acht heimischen kunden also
erhält auch und er dass sie erhält auch
eine rückmeldung wie viele dennoch
versteckt sind diesen ganzen bugs etwas
dahinter eigentlich liegt ist einfach
eine ein screenshot eine bilddatei als
chips in word erstellt eine screenshot
gemacht dann hochgeladen und dann
sozusagen immer markiert so einfällt
auswahl also wo ist es richtig wenn man
hin klickt und wo ist das ein sprung
hinkriegt
nächstes das spiel jetzt sind wir schon
bei der vokabel sucher der bankenkrise
im inhaltsverzeichnis jetzt ganz weiter
nach unten da würde es darum gehen die
studentinnen und studenten sehen oben
arabische wörter sie müssen die erstmal
für sich übersetzen dann das deutsche
wort im text suchen und natürlich den
druck noch ein bisschen zu erhöhen läuft
unten auch eine uhr also man sollte sich
auch unendlich zeit lassen man ist nach
zu viel
wenn sie das selber mal probieren sie
werden bestimmt allein durch
draufschauen schon einige wörter finden
im deutschen feld sagen viel springt ein
bisschen an das ist dann auch sehr
wahrscheinlich dass es ein arabischer
entsprechung des wortes gibt aber im
endeffekt müssen sie doch alles toben
dann mal übersetzen um wirklich alles zu
finden also haben das ausprobiert nur
allein also wenn man das arabisch um
komplett ignoriert und nur allein und
sucht dann wird man am ende nicht alles
finden
ein letztes beispiel ist ein drag and
drop beispiel hier wird es darum gehen
die arabischen länder die schon gewöhnt
formatiert sind den richtigen
dunkelgrauen kasten das ist lang zu
ziehen also unten stehen die länder
nahmen auf arabisch das prüft immer zwei
sachen ab zum einen ich mache das ganz
gern mit studenten so in der vierten
woche haben sie nämlich schreiben
gelernt und schnell lesen gelernt das
heißt sie können das unten schon
erzittern und sie können sich natürlich
ein bisschen überprüfen was sie von der
arabischen welt schon wissen auch der
typische aufgabe die ganze unbeliebt ist
natürlich interessant formen oder wenn
alle die zuschauen oder zu hören war
natürlich keiner gerne dann irgendwie zu
geben musste weiß es nicht so genau wo
ägypten zu finden ist oder wo irak liegt
also zusammengefasst kann man sagen
dieses buch als lernraum ich finde es
super dass mit h5 zu bestücken denn es
gelingt eigentlich viele ziele dieser
test zu vereinen zum einen ich finde das
sehr interaktiv das ist ansprechend das
funktioniert technisch gut studenten
können im eigenen tempo bearbeiten sie
erhalten direkt rückmeldungen und was
wir auch gemacht haben ist natürlich
dass studenten selber übungen andere
studenten erstellt haben im rahmen
dieser dieser rückblicke und auch das
kommt bei studenten immer sehr gut an
wenn sie hat wissen deshalb die
kommilitonen xyz erstellt ergeben sich
manchmal sogar noch ein bisschen mehr
mühe als wenn sie wissen das kommt nicht
von mir
trotzdem ist das natürlich auch also
dieses buch kann sie die studenten
einfach zu sagen geben und sagen das ist
der rückblick auf xy was auch immer sie
in ihrem fachbereich haben aber
natürlich kann man es auch gemeinsam
einsetzen in irgendeiner form der
präsenz lehrer also man kann es auch mit
dem beamer einfach vorne auf die tafel
werfen und dann gemeinsam darüber
sprechen was jetzt gemacht werden muss
um es zu lösen so in der einleitung habe
ich noch verkündet mit hafens hut
aufhaben vor werden das ist bei dem
beispiel jetzt gezeigt haben nicht ganz
so rausgekommen sie waren interaktiv ich
glaube das habe ich schon geschafft
sondern nicht unbedingt ganz so
farbenfroh deswegen hat es der letzte
folie auch noch ein paar beispiele für
farbenfroh gefunden für sie das haben
zum teil auch ständen und lehrende von
uns erstellt
2024 schneider und charlotte kuner
schneider links hat auch selber gemalt
also auch da ist sehr viel raum für
kreativität finde ich verfügbar was ich
sehr schön finde denn oft kommen spenden
auch ganz tolle ideen die ich selber
nicht gekommen wäre also mina zum
beispiel hat hier vor allem frage wörter
im kreis sozusagen geschrieben und dann
auch etwas farblich unterlegt die
aufgabe wäre es jetzt die boxen in der
mitte die deutschen zusagen auch das
passende frage bank zu ziehen
genau also es kann auch sehr farbenfroh
werden wenn sie eben viele bilder haben
und da content etwa zu erstellen
hinweisen möchte ich doch ganz kurz bei
dem
wohl so sagen rechts unten ist hier
dieser videos und im bett button das ist
das was ich vorhin gesagt hat zu teilen
ist sehr einfach möglich also man könnte
jetzt hier auf news klicken sie finden
es auch nochmal in der anleitung nicht
für sie geschrieben habe und dann könnte
man zum beispiel die ganze aufgabe
herunterladen sie könnten dann eine
anderen lehrperson diese aufgabe zum
beispiel auch per e mail schicken oder
natürlich in irgendeine cloud hochladen
was wir auch machen können ist dass sie
diese aufgabe sehr leicht durch mit
publizieren können also am beispiel
dieser aufgabe kann man ganz gut auch
mal den zeitaufwand und bisschen
klimatisieren ich hab's die selber
erstellt nicht wirklich mein leben
gelebt hat wie lange brauche ich und ich
habe insgesamt tut kommt da die zwei
stunden gebraucht also bilder
recherchieren zu schneiden diese boxen
erstellen dann hat es vermag wie ganz
lange nicht gepasst also es war
irgendwie immer zu breiten dann war
alles gestaucht und da ist sich gut aus
das finde ich jetzt schon im fall von
zeitaufwand dafür dass man dann so ein
kleines gadget eigentlich erstellt hat
aber wir haben bei uns im institut
festgestellt wir können es eigentlich
sehr leicht auf andere sprachen
transferieren also in unserem institut
wird auch angebotene persisch hebräisch
türkisch wir haben es live bei einem
anderen vortrag probiert und konnten das
innerhalb von zwei minuten abwenden für
die andere sprache und ich finde dass es
halt moment da wird es interessant also
wenn man content einfach wieder
verwenden kann wenn man ihn teilen kann
und wenn dann diese eigene gemachte
arbeit nicht völlig umsonst ist sondern
vielleicht auch jemand anderer noch
davon profitieren kann der halter nicht
zwei stunden lang irgendwie dran sitzt
sondern er deshalb ganz leicht in zwei
minuten ein übernehmen kann sie sein
fachbereich
zusammengefasst haben also ich finde es
hat sehr viele vorteile
mode wird interaktiver dadurch schwer
und muss es möglich es gibt sehr sehr
viele möglichkeiten was machen können
wir haben uns jetzt auf das konzentriert
ich finde die kann man darüber sehr gut
erstellen die sind gut geeignet sie
werden abwechslungsreichen tag 5 b
studenten können sich auch beteiligen
es gibt die möglichkeit dass
selbstkontrolle
das sind alles sehr positive sachen
natürlich im wo licht ist es auch ein
bisschen schatten also schon
thematisiert habe ich den zeitaufwand
den ich manchmal sehr hoch finde da kann
ich muss man sich selber als platzierung
auch ein bisschen disziplinieren
irgendwann sagen hier steht nicht mehr
im verhältnis
und dann gibt es natürlich auch
bestimmte technische grenzen von moodle
oder auch im hafen von nudeln zum
beispiel dieses buch hat einfach eine
bestimmte ein bestimmtes formaten
bestimmte form das können sie nicht
ändern da geht irgendwann nicht mehr
weiter die grenzen bei h 5b merkt man
vor allem wenn ich europäischen sprachen
wie in meinem fall also arabisch was ihr
von rechts nach links läuft zum beispiel
ich kämpfe immer damit dass am ende des
satzes wirklich der punkt steht also
wahrlich einen punkt setzte nach meinem
arabischen satz wanderte immer wieder
ganz nach rechts das heißt mein
arabischer satz beginnt immer mit einem
punkt dann kommt der arabische sagt und
am ende komplett punkt nicht mehr reicht
ihr nicht mehr hinbekommen das ist was
ganz spezifisches weil nicht
europäischen sprachen dass wir das haben
sie vielleicht gar nicht so ausgelegt
aber da kommt man auch drum rum wenn man
ein bisschen tricks und das trifft
sicherlich auch nicht jeden fachbereich
so stark wie bei mir dass man da auf
diese probleme stößt
damit wäre ich durch ich wäre jetzt sehr
neugierig auf ihre fragen kommentaren
und anmerkungen könnte mir vorstellen
dass sein oder andere zu nehmen um auch
harfenspiel vielleicht verwendet in
seiner lehre und ich würde mich auch
sehr dafür interessieren mit ihnen ins
gespräch zu kommen wie man vielleicht
ein bisschen respekt es ideen im bereich
hast die aufteilen könnte und vielleicht
auch darüber zusammen ins gespräch kommt
dankeschön